ja ich habe heute
mit bewunderung gesehen dass es menschen
gibt die auf seite 57 des wahlprogramms
oder des zukunftsprogramms der spd nach
geguckt haben und etwas unglaubliches
zutage gefördert haben dieser mann den
wir da jetzt sehen olaf scholz ist
sozusagen ein 11 milliarden man er kann
uns alle elf milliarden euro kosten und
das hat er da sogar eingeschrieben die
idee die dahinter steckt ist so
unglaublich
er will nämlich eine europäische
arbeitslosenversicherung er will also
wenn man das übersetzt dass wir mit
unserem geld sie mit ihrem ihr mit eurer
dich mit meinem
geradestehen für andere länder und ihre
arbeitslosen versicherungen also genau
genommen sollen wir das arbeitslosengeld
für spanier und griechen bezahlen das
ist eine der unglaublichsten gedanken
die zeit den übrigen schon lang um seit
2008 zehn da hat aber der altmaier
wirtschaftsminister noch auf ihn
aufgepasst und es abgeblockt jetzt wenn
olaf scholz kanzler wird hat er
angekündigt in seinem programm dann will
er das umsetzen und da muss man schon
mal sagen lieber scholz dann kümmern sie
sich doch bitte bitte mehr um die
deutschen als um die spanier und
griechen und anderen europäer kümmern
sie sich doch bitte bitte um die um die
sich die spd kümmern muss um menschen in
unserem land die weniger geld haben als
die anderen die ihre hilfe brauchen und
nicht um arbeitslose in irgendwelchen
anderen ländern oder kurz gesagt lieber
herr scholz machen sie doch politik nach
dem motto mehr bot und weniger brüssel
also ich muss sagen ich finde es richtig
gut und wichtig dass sie dieses thema
heute mitgebracht haben weil wir sehen
doch allein schon an ihre beschreibung
dass es für uns richtig teuer wird das
sind das sind die ideen von olaf scholz
und der spd und am ende haften die
deutschen arbeitnehmer die bürger
wirklich dann auch noch eu weit für die
politischen wirtschaftlichen missstände
die wir haben und es kann doch nicht
wahr sein irgendwo muss dann doch auch
mal schluss sein und vor allem wie geht
es dann weiter gibt es in eine eu-weite
rentenversicherung oder topf einzahlen
muss also da wir uns einig wären dass es
die vereinigten staaten von europa geben
soll und wenn wir uns dann auf
gemeinsame spielregeln einigen würden
dann halbe land wäre das möglicherweise
eine richtige initiative zuerst die
deutschen zahlen lassen und das andere
aber sozusagen nicht regeln das geht
nicht das war bei mir der moment
deswegen war ich vorher bei rot rot grün
so emotional jemand der das vorschlägt
also die vergemeinschaftung von
sozialleistungen der ist auch fähig rot
rot grün zumachen weil das ja ein
klassischer linker gedanken kann und ich
hoffe hier auf geschrieben hast du das
vorgestellt hast ganz wichtiges thema
sehr wichtiges thema das ist ein
vielleicht ist das ein game changer im
deutschen wahlkampf weil ich beobachte
etwas von außen eine ziemlich
unheilvolle entwicklung in der
europäischen union an verschiedenen
fronten dass man versucht deutschland
jetzt nach der merkur zeit nach der
schäuble zeit nach der zeit einer
gewissen finanzpolitischen vernunft in
die rolle des totalen nettozahler und
sponsors der europäischen union hinein
zu schieben und das ein olaf scholz der
völlig skurril als irgendwie politiker
der wirtschaftspolitischen vernunft
dargestellt wird wohl eher das gegenteil
ist dass er das sagt müsste für die cdu
das wahlkampfthema sein die cdu misst er
jetzt sagen wir verteidigen
den geldbeutel der deutschen gegen die
grünen verrückten die glauben dass man
die innovation durch verbote erzielen
kann und euch immer mehr energiekosten
lebenskosten dass man euch das auto
fahren den ganzen arbeitsweg alles der
tod und die verteidigen euch gegen traun
tänze wie diesen olaf scholz der im
grunde ein vabanque spiel macht mit
euren ersparnissen das auch jetzt
nachdem die deutschen ohnehin schon für
alles garantieren müssen müssen sie auch
noch die arbeitslosigkeit der spanier
der
italiener der griechen sponsern das geht
nicht aber das ist auch wieder ein
moment der wahrheit und da muss man
dankbar sein dass sich hier auch zur
kenntlichkeit entstellt hat jetzt muss
laschet vor hier auf dieses thema die
cdu die partei des deutschen
portemonnaies die partei der
finanzpolitischen handlung durchaus
sagen
das ist das modell arbeitslosengeld in
deutschland gastieren in der eu durchaus
gern gibt nämlich von menschen die
einfach aus der eu hierher kommen und
sich dann hier arbeitslosen arbeitslos
melden olaf scholz erspart in mit diesem
modell reicht nur die reisekosten
vielleicht klimatischen umstellungen
also durchaus ein sehr humanistischer
anders aber mein
bisher dagegen gerettet wird europa auf
dauer geben wird cdu auf dauer geben
wenn deutschland nicht bezahlt ich hab
da inzwischen meine zweifel also wären
wir schon oft zum beispiel über
europäische schulden gesprochen
ja und so sehr ich damit fremde muss ich
sagen ich glaube auf dauer wird können
wir uns entscheidend es wird die eu
weiter geben und dann zahlen wir für die
eu deutlich mehr als bisher oder wir
lassen halt die lebensverhältnisse in
der eu auseinander driften und dann wird
die eu auch auseinander punkt eins
europa gibt es seit tausenden von jahren
das wird auch die ard in europa wird
auch die eu überlege aber das problem
ist ja dass diese eu will jetzt mein
dieser you die wir jetzt haben ist ja
ein stabiles gebilde eine art cowboy auf
einem sumpf von schrottimmobilien das
ist eine schrottimmobilie
das wankt auf einem sumpf von das heißt
es ist nicht nachhaltig und es ist im
grunde eine frechheit dass von den
deutschen erwartet wird dass sie diese
dies funktionale struktur durchfüttern
also wir werden eine eu behalten aber
eine die
finanzpolitisch vernünftiger organisiert
ist und das scheint mir eine ganz
wichtige aufgabe der deutschen politik
zu sein jetzt wo die engländer draußen
seid ihr müsst ihr die stimme mit kommt
der reinen vernunft seien die
hauptschuldigen freunde das kann so
nicht bezahlt wird wir müssen das anders
organisieren und das schutz in diese
richtung marschiert das ist wirklich für
mich eine rote linie dir deine dunkelrot
eine rot rote linie die er da
überschritten und es zeigt auch dass wir
uns noch mehr bemühen müssen alle
miteinander insbesondere der politische
gegner also die cdu heraus zu ziehen was
in diesem schulz kopf alles drin ist
jener denn er schafft es ja selber nicht
zu thematisieren groß auf seite 57 ist
wahrscheinlich noch immer ein aus dem
wahlkampfteam der cdu war es ein fehler
ist und alles an sich abprallen jetzt
wäre eigentlich der modus jetzt haben
wir dich elf milliarden euro die zahl
nicht ich errechnet falls sie falsch
sondern christian lindner fdp
jetzt schwarz grün packt sich jetzt
sozusagen scholz mit dieser zahl wenn
dieser marke bundeskanzler wird sind
womöglich weitere elf milliarden euro
schwupps weg und man muss ja immer
wieder sagt schulz tut ja dann auch
immer so als wäre sein geld also er hat
wieder als finanzminister hat da
irgendwie geld ausgegeben noch mal kurz
es ist unser geld das wir ihm
anvertrauen und damit muss er dann
sorgsam umgehen und zwar im land zuerst
in einer der beliebtesten wahlkampf
tricks von von olaf scholz und der spd
im wahlkampf immer zu sagen olaf scholz
hilft da in der korona krise hat olaf
scholz wieder mit ex milliarden euro
geholfen in dieser flut an olaf scholz
wieder gehäuft und interessanterweise
aber das muss man ja nicht olaf scholz
vorwerfen das ist ja der billigste und
einfachste trick aber dass man so tut
als würde man menschen mit geld helfen
ist ja im wahlkampf zumindest
nachvollziehbar was mich wundert ist
dass die cdu nicht jedes mal sagt olaf
das ist nicht dein gelten es ist das
geld der steuerzahler
und es kommt von der regierung und nicht
von olaf scholz wir müssen etwas unruhe
können besser die hochhäuser als sieger
und hier haben aber die journalisten
tschuldigung habt ihr einen
intellektuellen führungs auftrag dass
ihr die cdu darauf aufmerksam macht und
auch die fdp und alle andern die sich
doch noch irgendwie bürgerlich nennen
auf diese missstände hinzuweisen und das
auch zu thematisieren ich mit welchen
kindern dekadentes emotionen kabuki
theater durchzuziehen wo die
ferngesteuerten kinderwägen welche
beschwerden frage stellen aus der
mystery torten studios sind doch
ernsthafte themen wo sind die aber wenn
die politiker versorgen wo sie in die
journalisten die das ganze thema die
sehen wo es die bild seien in der
schweiz die wissen in allen
gesprächen haben wir die früchte nach
weihnachten zurückgenommen ich möchte
nach deutschland der einzige schweizer
der nach deutschland flüchten
[Musik]